when I first moved out to LA I was
$10,000 in debt from obsessive online
comic book collecting and also
unemployed and in the beginning of my
job search I somehow found the creepiest
jobs imaginable although that was
probably my fault I found them all on
Craigslist but to my credit the job
titles lied one of the first jobs I
applied for was cocktail waitress I have
this suspiciously easy interview with
this old chain-smoking Chinese lady and
I should have known it was a bad idea
when she said any money don't you you
come to me as if that's not a red flag
enough but the job paid $18 an hour and
I was guaranteed at least $800 in tips a
night I had three cats to feed and the
ships were from 8 p.m. to 2 a.m. so I
could have the entire day for classes
and auditioning sounds perfect right so
it's my first day of work and I am just
sitting in a room with a bunch of other
girls and when I ask shouldn't we be
getting the place ready or something she
tells me you look really young that's
good you'll get picked a lot then our
first customers walk in it was a group
of old Asian businessman so we're
brought it to this dark lounge where my
boss flashes a flashlight in our face
and tells us to introduce ourselves the
girls are going down the line and I'm
freaking out convinced that I'm going to
be kidnapped and sold into slavery when
I realize that it's my turn
hi I don't say a real name don't see a
real name don't say your real name and
I'm an
my boss talked to the guys quietly until
she finally said Jasmine Holly and stay
and then I walked into the creepiest two
hours of my life
most of the men just wanted to talk
whether it was about their careers their
marriages or just how unhappy they were
the guy who picked me ended up holding
my hand and asked me to tell him a story
tell me a story when I first moved out
to LA I was ten thousand dollars in debt
from obsessive online comic book
collecting needless to say when they had
to go I was so relieved and when he
tried to tip me $20 my boss went apeshit
boy I'm not not Luke ended up forking
over $200 that was the first and the
last night I ever was a cocktail
waitress I left and I never came back
so the next time you go job hunting on
Craigslist
beware of old men who want to pay you to
hold your hand stay awesome Gotham
creepy as you can't as creepy as you can
I don't know what the fuck creepy is oh
you know what the fuck creepy is that
supposed to be you know creepy is your
creepy bitch no more time try not to
make any noise any auto voice just in
case hey basically shut the fuck up I
said it much nicer this time I really
like some of you you may be alive now
let's find a game called let's get
justify that fit this day okay oh my god